why
[Music]
too many times you close there use it
more as a little change in your can you
see that mean a pulse
boom
see that not maintain a constant flexion
okay my body I would watch to it watch
my body in check I can't tell I can't
tell what it's causing the percussion in
other words it's not okay and then you
watch this body and if it looks like it
has an immediate acceleration then you
know okay
so first you watch me mine voter voter
alive
[Music]
don't use mine the percussion spoke
already happened and the art was not
there when the profession happening
what's what is my grip doing then stay
with him stay inside his room that's not
Christian for questioning
boom yeah cuz he went down you see here
I get he hits that go back
he hit stop boom percussion why c'mon go
from here to here to stay with him he
comes in be stayin lower in my hands
with what I'm doing you're confusing
with showing him okay
any one of these technique I got there
same thing around her it's no meeting
each other say do we got around there's
no need to keep going I'm staying with
him I'm maintaining the I can teach okay
so we got the last one we're here boom
boom he comes in boom I'm staying with
you not pushing it down okay